man to train caramba darle más de
corazón que cara más fácil
visualicemos un estudiante de ingeniería
esa persona es hombre o mujer
ahora bien pensemos que se gradúa y se
dedica a la industria del petróleo la
imagen de hombre se hace un poco más
fuerte no soy mujer soy ingeniera y me
dedico a la industria del petróleo me
pongo el mameluco todos los días es una
imagen un poco más difícil de crear de
chica siempre fui muy curiosa en saber
cómo funcionan las cosas me la pasaba
desarmando electrodomésticos que después
no armaba para ver qué tenían dentro
cómo funcionaban al momento de estudiar
ingeniería yo no estaba al tanto de los
prejuicios o de los conceptos machistas
de la profesión la realidad sola se
encargó de mostrarme los en el primer
año de la facultad éramos tres mujeres y
más de treinta hombres
éramos minoría y les puedo asegurar que
en la carrera profesional este número no
es muy distinto en este aspecto de mi
primera experiencia profesional la
empresa en la que yo trabajaba me mandó
asaltar a un equipo perforador de pozos
en estas operaciones la persona
encargada y responsable de todo se llama
company man
y era el designado para mostrarme el
lugar y las tareas que debía realizar al
segundo día de estar ahí esta persona me
mira y me dice para mí las mujeres
tienen que estar en sus casas no en el
campo y siempre bien arregladas
me sorprendió y no contaba con
herramientas como para responder a ese
comentario me quedé pensando si
realmente era correcto que yo esté ahí
con el pasar de los días vi el poco
interés que esta persona tenía en mí y
decidí que tenía dos caminos o me
quedaba con su versión de la vida y me
volvía a mi casa o salir a buscar
herramientas y salía a buscar respuestas
y por la segunda me busqué aliados y
sobre todo me esforcé en demostrar que
no importa si es hombre o mujer con el
pasar del tiempo luego me fui
capacitando en este sector de la
industria y saben que terminé en el pues
mismo puesto que este señor y me
llamaban company woman
ahora bien las mujeres representamos la
mitad de la población es decir que la
mitad de nuestro potencial como sociedad
está ahí ahora cuando vemos carreras de
ciencia tecnología ingeniería o
matemáticas sólo el 33 por ciento de los
estudiantes es mujer en argentina por
ejemplo en santafé de todas las carreras
de ingeniería sólo el 24 por ciento de
los alumnos es mujer nos estamos
perdiendo de mucho potencial ahora bien
por un lado sabemos que no es biológico
no es natural sino que es cultural esta
diferencia de números por el otro lado
sabemos que los equipos heterogéneos y
diversos generan mejores resultados y
son más eficientes ahora cómo hacemos
para cambiar estos números nos animamos
a cambiarlos
tenemos un gran desafío como sociedad en
primer lugar tenemos que romper estos
paradigmas de hombre o mujer o de rosado
y celeste ya qué se dedica cada uno por
el otro lado tenemos que fomentar los
beneficios profesionales y personales de
estudiar carreras duras hoy en día ya
tenemos modelos de mujeres en posiciones
de liderazgo tenemos a jane fraser
primera mujer sí o the wall street'
tenemos a mero ibarra que es la
presidente ejecutiva de general motors
baja sin tarde en la ministra de nueva
zelanda es un ejercicio que tenemos que
realizar como sociedad
ahora bien
hoy en día yo trabajo en otra petrolera
que como muchas compañías comprenden los
beneficios de tener equipos diversos
comprenden la una simple ecuación que es
más visiones más perspectivas más ideas
mejores resultados a menor costo debemos
ir por este camino
de la diversidad para equiparar estos
números no solo para tener empresas más
exitosas sino para tener una sociedad
más justa
sólo seguí
[Música]